[Music]
[Music]
hey
everybody look we're alive yeah barely
yeah holy [ __ ] i'm not feeling all that
well
yeah i may not be here for the full show
we just depend on well we'll see how it
goes and he's not really drinking
because i'm not drinking i'm having a
drink because [ __ ] man of the last three
days
we've had i feel like i deserve one yeah
you know what i'm saying
you guys as i said in the message it's
been a day
well i mean the last three days have
been a day
but yeah holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i think it
was all interrelated now that i know
more about it what happened so let's
establish a timeline
okay and then so let me just say at the
outset i'm really sorry that we couldn't
stream you guys i felt really bad
but the first day i mean monday
we both just felt like hammered [ __ ] and
i don't feel like doing anything
and then yesterday i felt pretty much
okay but he was just like [ __ ] this i'm
not getting out of bed and i was like
okay well i didn't dead for three days
she had nicole
pretty much yeah that's what the whole
time yep
and uh yeah and i was like well i don't
really feel the need to do the live
stream without you because it was we
were gonna do coming to america and you
i knew you would probably want to talk
about that
so i was like well i don't want to do it
by myself but i will say that i did do
the movie retrospective that's coming
out on friday
or thursday if you're a patron i did do
that by myself because i didn't want to
because it needed to get recorded and i
didn't want to drag him out of bed to do
it
and it was mostly like a movie i wanted
to do anyway so i wasn't really worried
about it
so uh so the movie respective this week
will be just me
but okay so this is what happened now
like i said let's establish a timeline
for what happened
and then we'll say what we thought it
was and then today
there were new situations arose that
probably okay so sunday night
you had made um keema for dinner which
is
like a it's like a pakistani
um ground beef stew yeah like a soup
or a thin stew i guess you would call it
right so we ate it for dinner
sunday night it was delicious everything
was fine
monday we had some leftovers so we
heated up the leftovers for
lunch and we ate them and then like an
hour or so later
we both got sick same time uh yeah like
i'm sitting here in my office going man
i feel like crap it's like i could
barely keep my eyes open i said i think
i'm gonna throw up and it's like i felt
really shitty and then for a little
while i was just
i could kind of write it off maybe i
didn't get that good asleep or whatever
but then like after i started feeling
like no maybe i'm gonna puke
like tom came in the office he's like i
feel like crap i'm gonna throw up i'm
like dude me too
yeah and then we were talking like she
had already thrown up no i threw up
later
oh yeah did you throw it later yeah i
hadn't thrown up at that point i just
kind of felt nauseated like i was going
to
okay um so we both was like yeah we both
felt like way back in my room there
yeah and and the thing is is that i
don't know
you know i don't know if you guys have
how long you've been listening to the
show i've mentioned it before i can
throw up
at will yeah i learned to do it in the
army
it sounds [ __ ] crazy but in basic and
ait they'd force fetus water and they'd
punish us by making us drink entire
canteens of water
and they would just make you drink until
you threw up so what you
learned how to do eventually some of you
guys in basic back in my era
you just learned that if you could you
just learned that you can drink
a canteen of water and then throw up
immediately
and then you don't have to go through
the damn torture of [ __ ] drinking
four of them
yeah yeah so so
i went in there and just [ __ ] threw
up it felt good i felt i felt better
instantly
but then i went into bed got in bed and
um
fell asleep and slept for almost two
days three days didn't i
yeah yeah i didn't have any diarrhea
until like last night
some people are saying that the audio
sounds kind of janky but it's just kind
of like well
i'm not sure if i can do anything about
it now nothing has changed although i
will say that pookie ran in here earlier
and like kind of ran all over the desk
so i don't know if she did that
but um maybe you turn the volume down a
little bit is it no it doesn't no it's
the same
it's the same i haven't touched it yeah
so whatever it was i was trying to purge
it out
well what ha well what happened to me
like you came in and said you felt like
crap i was like yeah me too and he's
like i can't do the stream today i'm
like yeah i don't think i want to do it
either
i could barely get any work done because
i was like my head was [ __ ] falling
down on my desk and [ __ ] like that
and then um so he just he's like [ __ ] it
i'm just going back to bed so he want to
lay down i was trying to get work done
like a dumb ass
and then um so i just started feeling
really nauseated i was
kind of trying to fight it off because
for some reason i hate to throw up
i really hate it i don't fight it i
enjoy it see i
don't i don't know why i just really
don't like to do it so i really try not
to
and then so a few times i kind of felt
like i was going to but then i didn't
and like nothing came up
and then finally like at about 4 30 in
the afternoon i was like
uh oh and then like i really just like
puked everywhere and i was just like oh
man
and um then like but after that i was
like oh i feel a lot better
you know what i mean because i threw up
a lot and then
i felt better for a little while i was
like okay that's cool you know when i
came back and i got some more [ __ ] done
and then
i thought i was fine and then an hour
later i was like uh oh again and then i
threw up again
i'm like how could i have any [ __ ]
food left in my goddamn stomach i just
couldn't figure it out
so saying that it sounds bad unplug it
and plug it back in wait is this the
that's it it's this one yeah hold on
which one is it i don't know which one
it is
okay see how to see how is it better
okay can anybody
are you guys kind of like
can you hear us now i know i sound like
that commercial
man now everything's all [ __ ] up over
here they're not they're not [ __ ]
responding
well maybe it doesn't sound each other
maybe it doesn't sound weird
i mean it looks like it's still doing it
it says a bit cleaner
okay okay well like i said after we do
the stream i'll just have to [ __ ] i
don't
yeah that's a bit better okay all right
yeah don't [ __ ] with that too much how's
it now better
it's the same we hear you i can hear
sounds fine
okay maybe it's fine i don't know who
[ __ ] knows
but yeah so they said it sounds like the
volumes
volume's
too high that's really weird because i'm
pretty sure i turned
the gain all the way down on the back on
the back on the back
on the no on the back don't get it don't
get saucy with me bernays
yeah see the gain is all the way down
towards the minute no no no
no no no no no no no you don't want to
do that you turned this
up yeah what you did is probably why
good job it's okay
i don't know sounds okay to me some
people are saying it's a bit better
it's a bit better again it just sounds
like the volume is yeah i think that's
the problem we were having before
um it doesn't look like it's recording
from any other source
nobody's getting an echo right so maybe
it's just that
but like i said the gains still all the
way down because i think that was
problem too i think the gain was too
high before when i had it all
down but yeah so uh so yeah i had a
braft a bunch of times and then
i went in the room to see if he was okay
and then he was
sleeping and he'd been sleeping like all
day
two days yeah well he'd been some dude
i'm talking about the first day yeah
and he'd been sleeping all day and i was
like yeah i just like barfed up
you know should i ate like three months
ago and um
he was like oh he's like maybe i should
throw up i'm like dude i'm pretty sure
now that it's food poisoning right i
mean we thought yeah
it was weird because we'd eaten the
stuff sunday and it was fine
and then monday there really seemed to
be no reason but i was like it's gotta
be that because
it happened it came on like an hour
after we ate and we both
started feeling like crap at the same
time away i was wondering you know i'm
real good with the
food service safety i and i was like i
don't understand how
how that could have spoiled the only
thing i was thinking is that the night
before maybe it was too warm
when i put it away because i had it in a
pot and put the cover back on the pocket
but i don't usually do that well if it
stays a certain
temperature for too long in the center
of it it can kind of fester
but usually you can taste it and it
wasn't like it was a big pot
yeah so it wouldn't have been stayed it
wouldn't have stayed warm for long
yeah so i was that might not be good
okay so anyway i uh
well people are saying it's like too
loud so i'm just like backing it up a
little bit
zach just sent us something um i can't
read again
oh thanks exactly in 2013 i had food
poisoning so bad my stomach was messed
up for two weeks afterward and i barfed
so often i felt like i
like i worked out for 12 hours straight
yeah it's just i was really kind of
happy because
well after that we were kind of like
okay well it had to be food poisoning
that was the only thing i had that was
the only thing i had that i could
that was the only thing we had eaten and
we had both eaten it
and even though we'd eaten it on sunday
and nothing had happened
we figured well maybe you know maybe
while we were preparing it maybe we
touched something dirty and it like
you know what i mean and maybe cross
contamination that's all we can figure
out
yeah i couldn't understand it that was
the only thing i could
suspect was that it must have been that
food
until today and then today okay so this
is what happened
this is like and it seemed unrelated
until yeah
so today i go to do a load of laundry
like i do
pretty much every other day and while
i'm doing the laundry like while the um
the water is like draining out of the
thing in the washing machine
the water underneath our toilet and in
the bathtub
started backing up yeah and i was in
there
i was in there watching some youtube
some watching uh
youtube and i was in our bedroom
and i heard blue blue blue something
gargling
and i went up and looked at their big
bathtub and it was filling up with
sewage
yep i was going what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] and then i saw clear water coming
out
of the of the stall where the toilet is
because yeah because the toilet's in its
own it's in its own little stall
it's in its own little you know we got a
like a master bedroom type bathroom
what would you call that yeah that's
like one of those big yeah like a
bathroom it's a whole room you take a
bath
well yeah there's a stand-up shower and
there's a big garden tub
yeah and the toilet is in its own right
in its own little room
so i look at the toilet and clear water
is coming out from
thank you ken for the pepto teepee and
emoji made money
yeah cool waters coming up out
underneath the bottom of the toilet
and there's little specks of [ __ ]
stuff in it
and i'm going [ __ ] that's [ __ ] sewage
oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
yeah and um
so i called jenny i said what the [ __ ]
is happening and she's looking at it and
i'm looking in a damn bathtub
and i see [ __ ] jellified [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] and uh and it was because of the
and this it was the dryer was going
through its [ __ ] washing machine
the washing machine was emptying out all
the water from it
getting ready to go into the spin cycle
so i said something's been backed up in
this
plumbing system and i came in to check
because i have a bathroom right here
like off my office
and that was fun like the water in the
toilet there was low but like nothing
was coming up through the shower drain
or anything like that so i said it must
just be like at our end of the house
because
from the opposite end of the house as
the bedroom is and
and it dawned on me okay
the day that we got sick right before i
went over there and heated that food up
she was doing laundry and i found water
around the bottom of the toilet yeah
and i used a [ __ ] popped it up
and mopped it up because we don't think
anything about it yeah it didn't look
like sewage or smell like sewage i
thought it may be something you know
maybe it had come out through the back
you know you had that damn
i don't know i just it wasn't much it
was like a glass of it
yeah it wasn't it well hi pookie what's
up
she's looking up at me like what are you
talking about
so i mopped it up
make a long story short i believe that
was e coli poisoning or
something or it could be staph infection
what the [ __ ] no no no no i thought she
was gonna go behind it and then she was
like
see he's been doing this all day because
stop it because tom's been like uh
coughing and then he was mopping the
floors and we were bleeping everything
and so she was just like freaking out
and she ran in here earlier
and like if she knocked my this other
monitor over
she was like trying to hide behind the
thing for a little baby don't do it
don't do it i think she's asking dan
says cat
yeah so to get sick from raw sewage
it'll it only takes some microscopic
[ __ ] drought
droplets yeah it might have been you did
i mean i've been airborne and maybe i
breathed some of it in or some of it got
on my hands or i [ __ ]
when i went to wash that mop out and
ring the mop out i didn't
fully sanitize it somehow and i mean i
don't remember
touching the food but it just doesn't
matter you know what i mean it was
in there particle could have got on your
clothes it could have got you
transferred somewhere so i don't think
it was food poisoning i think it was e
coli or staph
somehow well i hate it i thought
that's what it was anyway but it's like
we just figured out where
the source of it probably was yeah and
we figured out because we're sitting
there going
we figured out why it backed up too yeah
okay so
for a long time like i said we use we
have a stand-up shower and i
and we use that all the time we have
like a big garden style tub
but i've really i've hardly ever used
that like
the whole 10 years we've lived here just
because it drained really slow
yeah it always drained myself the
plumbing in this place i always thought
was like really shitty because like even
the plumbing in the shower
yeah every now and then but i always
thought oh that's just because of my
stupid [ __ ] hair like coming out in
clumps every day
putting drano through it and clearing it
out constantly
yeah it's like we always you're wrong it
was the [ __ ]
bathtub this whole time the whole
[ __ ] 10 years
there has been [ __ ] like there's been
stuff like backing up in that bathtub
and it was [ __ ] up everything yeah
and it was uh
it had the kind of bathroom drain where
it
it's got a lid on it and you pick it up
and turn it yeah you're gonna like that
right i didn't know i never i'd never i
always hated that thing i like a real
plug like yeah yeah
well once it got raw sewage in it i was
like i got to get this out here
somewhere
somehow and he's a hero he
so i go i'm looking at that thing and
says how do i take that apart well you
go on youtube you gotta
just pick it up lift it pull on it the
internet is wonderful it'll come off
anything you want to learn how to do
yeah that's what that's that's all
that's all you got to do
so i added more water to it first you
know i mean to dilute it
get it you know i mean i wanted it to be
nice and weak i didn't want extra
strength
raw sewage so i diluted it straight
throughout the image
so i diluted that [ __ ] first and then i
took the
top off and [ __ ] hurt her to go gluck
i don't know what and i reached down in
there and pulled it out and there's a
big wad
of [ __ ] hair and pieces of plastic
and two quarters that have been in there
for [ __ ] forever
yeah they were like two quarters yeah
since we've been here somebody
had been the people that lived here
before us those two quarters
what they were doing is caused a clog
that was
real bad and it got and because we
weren't using the bathtub
over time somehow
the claw got worse and haven't had to do
with ventilation i don't know everything
i don't i don't really understand
anything about how plum plumbing works
but there's that [ __ ] has to be
ventilated or you don't have
proper yeah ken was saying earlier that
they had like an air bubble or an air
pocket or something like that yeah
it must have been an air pocket in the
tub and it was because it was backing up
the toilet the shower
and the shower and the washer and the
washing machine
because it's all kind of on the same
side of the house as soon as i took
those two coins out of there and
and pulled everything out pull that and
everything out everything left the damn
house
went right down yeah and i did another
little laundry after that yeah no no
problem
and then turn the damn shower on and it
doesn't even [ __ ] collect water in
the bottom of the shower it just goes
right out through the bottom
[ __ ] it was so hard sometimes it would
get to where you better standing in an
inch of water
and if you're there trying to [ __ ]
trying to uh
plunge it plunge the damn thing and take
the [ __ ] grill off and plunge it and
i'm like why the [ __ ] does this why does
this water not go down
sometimes it would yeah yeah sometimes
it would go down something's fine yeah
it's just that's what it was and yeah we
[ __ ]
i went up to because he was like he's
like okay well i can't leave this
bathroom because this is a biohazard
area
so i said well i hadn't been in there so
i said okay i'm gonna put on some shoes
i'm gonna run up to walgreens i'm gonna
get some drain out and some bleach and
some whole bunch of other stuff i had a
little bit of bleach but not a lot
yeah i said i'm gonna go get a whole lot
of bleach and a whole lot of drano yeah
and so
here's the shitty thing i went to
walgreens which is only that's like less
than a mile from our house it's like
right around the corner
i go there they had all kind of bleach
so i got a big [ __ ] jug of bleach i
got some bleach spray i got some bleach
gel i got all kind of [ __ ]
and then they had zero drano no drano no
liquid plumber no nothing
they had nothing and i was just kind of
like what the [ __ ] man so then i had to
drive
again to [ __ ] publix and they were
also out of drano although they did have
liquid plumbers so i got like two big
huge things of liquid plumber
so we came back to the house we poured
drano down every available drain
put bleach all over everything you know
filled the tub up with bleach water we
like [ __ ]
bleached them up we bleached the floor
we bleached everything
so hopefully everything's okay we're
trying to keep beijing out of there
because she really really digs the smell
of bleach
and we didn't want her she mostly does i
don't think she licks it or anything i
think she just likes to roll around in
it which is
a rag doll they um like the smell of
bleach
yeah i'm not really sure but i think a
few other breeds too but we were looking
that up because
every time i clean the bathroom with
bleach spray or something like that you
have to keep her out of there because
she just
it's like catnip yeah she'll come in
there and be like
wow bleach should choose like rules i
have a video of her doing it it's like
the craziest [ __ ] thing you've ever
seen
she [ __ ] loves bleaching better
bleach everything yeah yeah
i bleach everything down [ __ ]
[ __ ] put the clothes off putting it
back in the washer [ __ ] all kinds of
stuff
i i disinfected everything yeah i mean
i'm
really happy that that's fixed now it
was it had to be that
i mean all that because like i said we
didn't notice it because we hardly ever
use the tub
yeah and the only time i turn the water
on is to clean it
it took a long time for it to reach
critical mass
that's what i actually got to the point
where it couldn't it caused huge air
pockets
to form and then it was like backing
everything up and the [ __ ] washing
machine and everything like that
so but i kind of feel like the whole
sick thing i don't think anything to do
with that food now
well yeah because i didn't know that
that was raw sewage well yeah well
like i said you wouldn't yeah it didn't
smell like it it didn't look like it
looked like clear water
now you know what i came right now but
i'm thinking about it this is like the
grossest discussion ever
i told you guys it's gonna be gross um
now that i'm thinking about it every now
and then
because like i said the shower would
back up like every now and then kind of
a recurring problem like i said and he
always kind of blamed it on my hair i
thought it was my hair too to be honest
with you but um
a few times in the past there have been
like little puddles of water
that's it right underneath the toilet
that's what it is
and it's like you don't really notice it
because you're just kind of like oh
maybe the toilet maybe it's got a little
leak or something like that somewhere
but then it doesn't happen again so then
you're just kind of like oh well
whatever that's what it was it's only
and it was only about three inches
three inches thick and real shallow
yeah that's the way it was when i first
saw it but then when
when it was backing up real bad today
i ran over there and looked at it wanted
to see if there was any water there and
it was squirting out like it was
squirting out from a hose
yeah yeah it filled that cubicle
yeah and it had a little little [ __ ]
yellow flakes floating in it
at least it didn't smell that bad i mean
it smelled kinda bad
you could do it with sewage then yeah
and i mean in this other bathroom i
didn't really
we didn't have anything coming up in
this other bathroom but you could smell
a little bit
if you were searching for it it wasn't
so much where you'd walk in and be like
holy [ __ ] it wasn't like that
you do not want [ __ ] in your house
people
and then i had i was confined to
i was i was confined into that [ __ ]
bathroom because i was wearing boots and
you had it all over again it was all
over my boots that's why you said i
can't leave the bathroom
in my bathroom go to walgreens get the
fish
across the carpet in the [ __ ] yeah
because you're just tracking it
everywhere
because i only had like i said i only
had about a half a bottle of bleach
spray
because we our big jug was gone so i had
to go up and get another
bunch of chunks of bleach yeah but uh
no i i thought i did something wrong
with food storage but
no it was that was either a coli or
staff
from ross i suspected it was staff even
from the beginning because
i didn't think it had anything to do
with the food itself i thought it was
some kind of cross-contamination from
somewhere i said maybe
i said you know what maybe one of the
cats climbed up on the
um counter like while we weren't looking
yeah and they came out of the cat box
and then they just came out of the cat
box because it's like i don't usually
see them do that but every now and then
i'll come out in the morning and pookie
will be like up on the bar and i'll be
like hey
and then she'll be like what i just i
wasn't on the bar i don't know
something that got contaminated with
yeah yeah
that [ __ ] sewage somehow yeah we
shared a drink or something and forgot
it so yeah
it had to be something like something
like that because
but the weird thing is like myself maybe
i pulled bowls down and [ __ ] wiped
my bowls with the hands like you know or
something
oh you know what it was what i know what
it was
i uh the rice
came out of that ziploc bag and the
[ __ ] put the rice into one bowl
all right see that's why i told you to
throw the rice on your tail yeah we did
throw the rice
i put it into one bowl and reached and
grabbed into that bowl and put it in the
tube
so that would have been enough mystery
solved yeah
yeah mystery solved yeah because too
much came out in one bowl
yeah and you know my hands were clean
you know but like i said all it takes is
all just one little
yeah i had washed my hands but i didn't
wash them like i knew i had just been
dealing with raw
sewage and how [ __ ] with bleach and
all kinds of stuff
you know yeah like i said you weren't
thinking about it i wouldn't really
think about it right
so that's the top point i touched the
food
yeah yeah i remember the rice
yeah that's probably okay well that
explains it and here's
that's how you got it i would have got
it anyway because it probably
would have been on me i've been touching
my own pants or something like that or
yeah
you know which is maybe why i got it
worse
yeah because i was going to say that i
puked
like uh apocalyptically like two times
felt like i was gonna puke a few times
after that but then didn't or nothing
came up but those two times
like i said i threw up [ __ ] that i ate
like months ago um
so it but it felt good like afterward i
was like thank god like everything was
emptied
but then like the next day i had like
real bad acid reflux
like all that night probably until about
three or four a.m
um because i slept for about 12 hours
like off and on after that
but when i woke up the next morning i
felt pretty much okay
i didn't go on my hike because i was
like i don't think it's a good idea
because i felt kind of weak
um so i said well i'll just like you
know sleep in a little bit and
rest some but i felt pretty much okay
and then i got up about 9 or 10 a.m i
said you know i
i think i'm not hungry but you know even
though
obviously yesterday i didn't eat
anything because the one thing that i
ate i threw it all back up
i was like i'll just eat like two pieces
of toast and
if that stays down then later i'll eat
something else
you know so i did that and the toast was
fine and then like a few hours after
that i said okay well
i'll just have like bowl of chicken soup
and that was fine too and then i'm like
okay well i must be fine
but then you still felt really really
bad like yesterday i don't think you
were
even any better no really you stayed in
bed all day yesterday
yeah i was in bed for two days yeah t um
i already
pretty much did that uh and everything's
all bleached down it's it is good
i talked about fill the tub up with
water and bleach and everything
and yeah talking to landlords there's
really no use in talking to the
landlords
i got a really good uh relationship with
them
um yeah there's a lot of the [ __ ] that
form and they just take it out for my
rent
yeah you know and i already fixed it
because i i traced it it was those
there were two damn two quarters
have been in there i think i think they
were quarters
they were quarter sized and i could just
see i mean they were black but you could
barely
see the little eagle on there they were
they were corroded because i've been
putting drano down in there trying to
unplug that right yeah so they must have
been down there from over five years
and it was blocking up the [ __ ] tub i
said oh now the tub now we can maybe
actually use it yep
and uh that and having that clog in
there [ __ ]
caused big air bubbles to form and you
couldn't get proper flow
yep so but now everything's it as soon
as we [ __ ] cleared that
everything in the house started working
fantastic which i'm
really happy about who who would have
thought the whole time like the whole
time we've lived here and i bitched
about like man the plumbing in this
place is so shitty it was just so
and it was just that [ __ ] bathtub it
was that bathtub
causing all the problems but uh you know
who knew
but well that's the thing and it's like
we were actually going to
because i told them before we had
figured out what it was i was kind of
like well
we should call the landlord and have
them call a plumber and sort this [ __ ]
out because
you know they own like 12 or how many
houses do they have you know
40 of these oh they own 40 houses again
they rent them out people
yeah and um so they're really nice and
uh it's like a family yeah they're
they're uh they're from spain yeah yeah
yeah
and um you know they like i said they
like us because we take care of the [ __ ]
we don't bother them unless it's
something really like you know the air
conditioning or something like that
you know or the roof or whatever um but
i was like well maybe we should call
them and see if they know a plumber that
can come and then he was like well it'll
probably take a few days i said well
maybe
we should just call a plumber and pay
for it yeah and then
i was like no i'm pretty sure then he
was like no i think it's the tub
yeah it's just product the process of
elimination yeah
and i kept tracing it back to that
[ __ ] bathtub
yep that's what it was well yeah like i
said that's now that you fixed that it's
kind of like
everything seems to be working fine i
ran the i you know i did a load of
towels in the washer and why was it
trying to vent there
why did it all come up out of that
bathtub if it was trying to vent there
yeah it tells you that
there was a clog yeah and like i said
kind of vent gas there
the tub's been like that like forever
which is why i don't really use it like
i said the only time i turn that water
on ever is when i'm cleaning the tub and
it
and it always takes like forever for the
water to drain out because it's just
like really really slow
and i always thought oh well you know i
i thought because of that and because of
the shower i was just like well
you know the the plumbing in this place
is just really shitty or it's really
cheap or whatever yeah tea you can drink
from the tap here
yeah i have drinks we filter everything
i mean we have a brita and we have a
filter in the front of the refrigerator
yeah our refrigerator dispenses ice
but i drink water out of the tap all the
time yeah well [ __ ] i'll just i'm too
lazy
if i get out of bed in the middle of the
night i'm too lazy to go to the kitchen
and get water i'll just drink out of the
bathroom that [ __ ] grows
it's just water i've i've been drinking
tap water out of florida taps
since i was a child yeah i mean i didn't
when i was growing up i didn't have
filters or anything like that i just
drank water right out of the sink i
don't care you have
of water and i'm still yeah and i'm
still alive the south didn't have
bottled water that's a [ __ ] yankee
concept
now the only time the only place i was
at that i wouldn't drink water out of
the tap
was my aunt and uncle's house which was
in
ormond beach which is a little bit north
of daytona beach
and for some reason their water tasted
like it didn't taste like
sulfur or anything like that because
sometimes you get that their water
tasted like
grass it tasted like water that had been
sitting
on the grass you know what i mean and if
for some reason i just couldn't get into
it
but the water i drank it like all the
houses i grew up in just tasted like
water it didn't taste like anything
yeah you know what i mean it wasn't bad
remember when we were kids
first time we saw a bottle of perrier
water that's back in what late seventies
that was like super fancy but it was
like yeah
what the [ __ ] is this they're selling us
water and you're putting the water in a
bottle
oh we gotta try this chasing
yeah tastes like [ __ ] it does i don't
like that [ __ ] needs to be sweetened
well the only thing that's good for is
mixing it with like
licks or something right it's like why
else does it exist
i don't want to drink it by itself so i
had i had a bad experience of
bottled water at first it took me a
while to get to to get used to that
i mean remember it started to become
cheaper if you put it in plastic
yeah filthy gardner says alligators pour
out from florida's
happened at some tabs and tila says
perry it tastes like water with baking
soda and yeah that's exactly what it
tastes like it's like who the [ __ ] would
want to drink that i couldn't understand
that man like i said mix it with gin
okay yeah you're talking but other than
that no thanks
we were in mississippi just trying to
fathom that [ __ ]
came in that pretty green bottle you
know i mean had a commercial on
television
yeah trying to get us to buy that
[ __ ] water
yeah it should taste like [ __ ] tasted
terrible
i still remember one of the funniest
waters much better
well yeah and like i said everywhere and
i don't know i can't speak to all of
florida just where i grew up in florida
other than that with the exception of
that one neighborhood where my
uncle lived with their water tasted
weird and grassy but i think
um everywhere else that i lived in the
central florida area the tap water
tasted just fine it didn't taste weird
it didn't taste like anything
you know what i mean although i will say
i think where we live now
i think uh we have a little bit of a
hard water problem because sometimes
the water will turn the shower orange
yeah like it comes and goes you notice
that
yeah so you know what i mean so that's
probably what the
my insides look like they're all rusty
definitely isn't that funny that's what
my grandmother used to say
because all i would ever drink when i
was growing up was water i didn't like
soda
and uh she always said drinking all that
water it'll rust your pipes
that's what she used to say my grandma
all she ever drank was coca-cola
so all right um been talking to uh
talking to some of you guys directly on
here jenny and i are re-watching
spartacus sand and blood blood and sand
yeah well i didn't know they made four
seasons four seasons we've only seen
we've only
well we've saw the first one and then we
started watching the second one and it
wasn't as good so i think
no no didn't finish the second one yeah
i don't remember anything the second one
is told from another about the other
the other guy yeah that one was good too
and then remember that was season three
that we started
and didn't like okay i'm just
remembering that had the new
that had the new uh the new guy well
because the original guy
died i'm pretty sure it was season three
anyway uh
if you guys haven't seen that you guys
might want to check out spartacus
that's uh that's a gladiator gladiator
[ __ ] movie you know what i mean i
mean it's very much like 300.
yeah it's it it's what what i would call
you know
macho sexual
that's a new one yeah i'm metrosexual as
a mattress
section um it's nothing but [ __ ] hot
muscle dudes and hot women [ __ ]
walking around halfway so many boobies
yeah so much playing each other and
[ __ ]
just getting cut off
[ __ ] married couples with their
[ __ ] sex slaves [ __ ]
fluffing on them before they get in and
then it's all kinds of [ __ ] cool [ __ ]
happens in it
uh about roman [ __ ] roman glady a guy
running a roman gladiator school and
he's living beyond his means he's
constantly falling into debt
he's got to do all this [ __ ] destiny
[ __ ] it's got
no it's it's badass it's pretty
it's pretty accurate to uh roman culture
and gladiator gladiatorial sports um
my knowledge of roman culture ancient
roman culture and roman history is
pretty good
uh and uh it does a lot of the series
matches up now not
not all the fashion does but the real
roman fashion would that wouldn't look
that good on camera
uh yeah it's cinematic it's synthetic
right
uh some of the helmets and [ __ ] they
used were kind of from the wrong era
you know but and you know the helvetii
didn't [ __ ]
look the way they did but they did that
in 300 too yeah they kind of made some
of the people like some of their enemies
look like
monster monster essentially like or a
human monster hybrid
i guess right tammy said what is it on
it was on stars
um but you can watch it on amazon prime
with commercials they have all four
seasons on there but like we've seen the
first one's the best one
um i haven't well i haven't seen three
and four we started watching
like i said we've maybe seen two but it
i don't remember that much about it
maybe
the first scene this season is from 2010
yeah
oh yeah they're talking about crixus
yeah crixus was good i mean if he likes
300 you'd
probably be super into it and plus i
love one of my favorite things about the
show because i guess i'm a writer and
i'm really into like language and i've
got really good writing and i love
swearing
so i really like all the roman specific
like ancient roman specific swears
yeah that they come up with getting hit
in the head with jupiter's [ __ ]
i mean heaven rolling back and having
jupiter drop his nuts on you
they just say all this [ __ ] i mean i
just love that so yeah [ __ ]
pluto's [ __ ] me in the ass [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah like well that's kind of what you i
don't know if that's exactly what they
would say but that's
kind of what you would say you would
because most swears
came from like religion or being like
blasphemous right
so well actually no having jupiter
[ __ ] drop his [ __ ] on you
would not be blasphemous to an ancient
roman
no i just meant that that yeah it was
but that was just uh
[ __ ] they were talking they just had
you know they were constantly bringing
up the gods and how the gods were
[ __ ] them
yeah you know um with misfortune and
[ __ ] yeah the gods are [ __ ] on me
today and stuff like that yeah put some
of this in your mouth you know they're
just
[ __ ] funny
and he and he's a real oh the gods are
pissing and [ __ ] on me today and
then
definitely
and his wife were probably like my
favorite cat yeah and his wife is played
by lucy lawless
yeah yeah yeah and she's just like at
the zenith of her hotness
she's probably about 50. yeah she's
super happy [ __ ] incredibly high
and i love her her and that catty [ __ ]
that's going there
they're having threesomes and [ __ ]
eventually and [ __ ] smacking each
other
but it's definitely you know that
they're [ __ ] i mean if you're like
blood and gore and boobies i mean well
they're pretty [ __ ]
good of humanity which is sex
violence and corruption and just [ __ ]
lust for power and they [ __ ] turn
that all the way up but
and that's the way really the way a
roman elites were
they were but by today's standards they
would have been
they were kind of demonic they they were
demonic
basically scribble official says she was
hot as [ __ ] ash versus evil dead i
agree
that was actually one of my favorite
series from the last few years ash vs
evil dead that was [ __ ] amazing
i i still laugh about bruce campbell
coming out of that corpse's ass
hole yeah bismuth says you see penis in
it
no uh no erect penises but you do see a
lot of limp penises yeah
yeah because a lot of the gladiators at
the school naked all the time
like they would have yeah they did it's
it's accurate pretty accurate
and uh all the slaves kinda the slaves
and the ludus
all kind of had their own intrigues
going on where they were trying to hook
up with each other and some of them were
having sex with the [ __ ]
like [ __ ] the mean champion gladiator
james chris and this
and jen i was jenny and i was looking at
him you know i'm looking at this dude
and i'm going jen you know what
you know what jenny says that's a real
good looking dude
and she's like yeah all of a sudden i
was like
i'm thinking i said man i [ __ ] wish i
looked like that dude
okay anyway he's hooking up with his
[ __ ] with batiatas his [ __ ]
master's wife
um and he's [ __ ] giving her gifts and
[ __ ] with his little meager winnings and
she's [ __ ] eating it up and [ __ ]
his attentions and [ __ ] and it's like
it's just but then like her fluffer
which is like her [ __ ] handmaiden is
really in love with him and
he's kind of in a way getting all the
women cryxus
yeah he shows up to the [ __ ]
gladiator fights and [ __ ] these all
these rowdy women [ __ ] showing them
their tits and he's like going yeah yeah
and um it's just a real good writing
um good human stories a lot of [ __ ]
combat a lot of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
inhuman
inhuman cruelty [ __ ] just inhuman
wastes of people's lives
just remember when they [ __ ] had it
that hasn't happened i forgot
the blonde curly hair guy who sold
himself in his slavery yeah yeah
they killed him at a party yeah it's
just literally just as a
dare yeah yeah just because if you have
money then
what does it matter if he dies right
because life was meeting yeah
body artist was like uh he was like well
i paid good money for that dude you know
what i mean [ __ ]
and he goes no it should be to the death
you know and [ __ ]
killed the dude at a party they weren't
even out of damn [ __ ] and
and made made spartacus do it yeah
because rich people are like david's
dance
yeah for entertainment yeah they grab
them and make them have sex with each
other and sit there and watch at the
dinner party
yeah like i said that that crazy catty
[ __ ] that's on there yeah she goes
oh he he listened to that and [ __ ]
[ __ ] he put on a good show
[Laughter]
i know i'm 27 but [ __ ] stop [ __ ]
we don't have viagra in here
you know like what i gotta [ __ ] the same
one well you know
hey i came from an animal breeding
background i know exactly
how it's bring the next mayor in here
that's what i mean
yeah he'll be here he'll be good to go
you know
a new one okay okay yeah all right i'm
ready i'll get this one too
it's a fun show is what we're saying
yeah yeah we just decided it was weird
because
we saw it um probably a year or two
after it came out i think
because i think wasn't it on netflix for
a short time we didn't see it right when
it came out because i don't think we had
stars
but um and we weren't even living here
then i don't think
and i know we were here when we watched
it so i think we saw it a year or two
after it came out
and then for just whatever reason like
last night i was just kind of like
yeah i'm kind of tired it's like i don't
really feel like watching anything in
particular and he's like for some reason
i really want to re-watch
spartacus like the series and i was like
okay i want to see if it held up
it got better with age like it's very
very 300
in the sense that it's not quite as
comic booky but it does have a lot of
those like
freeze frame kind of like blood splatter
like arm flying and [ __ ] like that it
does have that kind of stuff
but it's not quite as comic booky like i
said
and there is a lot of i mean one of my
favorite things
is lucy wallace's character and that uh
and that catty [ __ ] character i can't
remember what her [ __ ] name is
she's in the she's the preacher no she's
the
legatus is [ __ ] white yeah yeah but i
can't remember what her name is like a
24 year old just
[ __ ] she's just a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] man i mean
you're the terrible terrorist every
[ __ ] thing she says is just some kind
of [ __ ]
oh well how disappointing oh yeah
everything is either
just like a straight up like everything
she's so passive aggressive and
everything she says is like either a
backhanded compliment or just kind of
like she's just the [ __ ] worst
she's oh i don't have any children oh i
would say i would have thought that a
woman your age would have
my mini children yeah it's just like
she's always like i think i think she
says
everybody and even like the [ __ ] with
the emerald necklace because
the whole thing about the emerald
necklace yeah and he's like oh that's so
beautiful i remember what's his face
like the dude that sells him the jewelry
i remember
i remember him showing me that and it's
like i have one like that you know when
emeralds were in fashion
he's like oh [ __ ] i'm just gonna kill
you right now
like so i love the interplay between the
two of them because i'm just like oh i
love all this [ __ ] [ __ ] but the men in
this are a little [ __ ] too
yeah well the gladiators it's it's just
not as refined as the women's bitchiness
i guess
yeah well the gladiators are all just
trying to outcock each other i mean yeah
the men are usually just like you have a
small dick because you have this no
small baby you smell like a girl you
know you smell like
[ __ ] yeah they're not real creative
well it's just i'm gonna kill you yeah
you're next
oh my god britney said it sounds like my
mother-in-law
oh yeah yeah i've known many people like
that
she gets hurt eventually
some dudes too i've known some dudes
that were that were like that but a
certain type of woman
usually a real kind of pretty one like
that um
that's just something that they do and i
don't even know i sure i'm sure they
know what they're doing
obviously because they everything is
just calculated to cause the greatest
amount of hurt while still
maintaining plausible deniability that
you didn't mean anything like that
you know what i mean yeah like
everything is just real calm saying that
there's a documentary about that guy
fighting off that himself he was some
kind of leukemia wouldn't it
yeah oh [ __ ] i'm gonna have to see that
i'm like so [ __ ] sad
he's so young and he went down fighting
yeah he was the star of the show
he was good good he's in real good shape
yeah
like in his first season he's in amazing
shape yeah
mike asked do we ever see the show roam
i haven't but a lot of people have
recommended that to me so i'm sure i'll
get around to it one of these days
you know what i mean all right so we
should probably talk about what it is
people want to hear about you know that
they want to hear about
coming to america well because i keep
teasing about it because we were going
to do a matinee on it and then we got
sick and we couldn't [ __ ] come on and
talk about it
okay we gotta talk about it now i will
note i did get a very funny
message or very funny comment from mango
who said don't worry about it i felt ill
after watching coming to america
okay yeah it was that that made us like
no seriously
it wasn't i'm gonna say it from the
outset um it was an enjoyable movie
yeah i had a good time with it yeah it's
not as good as the original i'm not as
good as dolly mike
it was the same director though i didn't
realize that it wasn't as good as
dolomite
no not by a long shot but it wasn't a
terrible i didn't feel like i'd wasted
my time or anything like that
it was fun and i had a good time with it
but
i think it had some issues but it wasn't
as bad as i was expecting
had a pacing issue right after i think
that was the main part of it
um they were [ __ ] flash is a [ __ ]
genius in it
how they ended the story of the king was
just [ __ ] great
james earl jones with morgan freeman
that's a [ __ ] funeral
yeah god god at the door yeah hilarious
that whole funeral scene the king the
the king
played by james earl jones decides that
yeah he's going to die and he's going to
have the best funeral
and [ __ ] all kinds of [ __ ] you know
he's isn't that in [ __ ]
eddie or [ __ ] what [ __ ] eddie
murphy's character promises
to akim akin yeah akeem promises him the
best [ __ ]
funeral of all [ __ ] times and [ __ ]
the king is like yeah let's do it now
well we've got to be able to enjoy it
let's do this let's have a look
so i want to see what you guys come up
with he goes to his own funeral alive
he's in the damn coffin alive
and [ __ ] observing and he's enjoying
it all all the songs and [ __ ] are yeah
all the songs and the songs are [ __ ]
great
it's [ __ ] morgan freeman [ __ ]
basically standing for
god talking to it's brilliant
comes over to the [ __ ] coffin and
it's the coffin stan
standing up and [ __ ] the king's in it
and he goes you're right my son this is
the best [ __ ] funeral ever
it's time to it's time for me to die now
and he goes
okay he dies that's it
father father he's dead okay just you
know
he's awesome yeah he dies when he wants
to die
well yeah because he's the [ __ ] king
that's why andy james earl
the story kind of went through about a
five or a ten minute
kind of time where they go back to
[ __ ] brooklyn and it's
square he's not brooklyn what's that
queen yeah yeah they
go back to queens and and [ __ ]
uh the pacing started to fall apart for
me
it was a little long i think that some
of it could have been taken out or like
trimmed up a little bit they started
introducing
hakeem's bastard son turns out he had a
bastard son
through one of the girls and yeah they
kind of like uh back maneuvered that
like
which okay so it kind of
but then it kind of picked back up again
it did have some enjoyable stuff
uh with about his with his you know
akeem's daughters and what they were
doing and we started doing more of them
actually right
they didn't really get a lot of screen
time i mean other than mika who was the
oldest one
he had two other daughters and it's like
i feel like they
they could have focused more on the
daughters i think that would have been
cool well i think they tried to as much
as they could yeah
i think the problem there was just a
little bit too much going on i think
maybe maybe the plot was a little
overstuffed yeah
it was overstuffed because they tried to
insert a bunch of differing messages
into the movie including a pot
apologizing for the first movie
which you never do that okay um
like you know uh arsenio's hall's
character we played the [ __ ] priest
like
these girls yeah i mean all this kind of
stuff you know the ones that were
he had the beauty contest with his name
yeah yeah he was acting as a priest
on two occasions they referred to him as
that sexist guy
so they're telling you how to feel about
the character don't
don't tell the audience how to feel
about the character
it's not funny and you're not
apologizing for that character you
shouldn't have to
it was [ __ ] funny all right
comedy is only funny when it's
subversive allow things to remain
subversive
don't try to [ __ ] back off of
something it's just like if you
i ain't gonna go that far when i'm gonna
talk about how much there's like sexual
equivalence to that
if you're in there man don't deny that
you're in there you're in it
you're talking about i'm sorry that's it
slipped no you know it's
that's
that's what they tried to do what's on
the web form i did it just went right
yeah it slipped and it [ __ ] went in
the wrong hole
don't
[ __ ] you talking about don't apologize
for for
what made eddie murphy so [ __ ]
hilarious
in those days is that it was subversive
humor okay
uh and we're living in a new era of
cancer culture so
by backing up off backing
up off of the [ __ ] comedic
quality of the past by backing off of it
you're betraying what it was
and you're also admitting that you did
something wrong would never admit that
you do anything wrong
you're always well i don't know if
that's that's hot or not well is that
it's more when it comes to heart well
when it comes to art okay if you kill
somebody or something like that no no
just we'll talk this is art and humor
never back off that
in fact you lean into that [ __ ] well if
it was funny
yeah i mean if it wasn't funny he should
have come out and been more subversive
all right top it they they you want
these [ __ ] [ __ ] in the media
to go out and condemn the movie if they
go oh this thing is [ __ ] terrible
it's racist sexist homophobic
transphobic misogynist
and you're guaranteeing it's success
everybody will go see it
they will okay because that's how
that's how he got famous in the [ __ ]
first place
but you see they're all scared of
getting canceled so whose dick are they
riding who do these people work for
is this some kind of a [ __ ] corporate
back thing
is it is it is it are these uh
[ __ ] what do you call them are these
independent films i
i thought they were but maybe they're
not this one was actually made and i
didn't know this until i looked it up
after
it was made by tyler perry's uh you know
he makes the media movie yeah what the
[ __ ] it was made at his uh
i would have gone balls deep in there
and the problem too is that one it was
pg-13
which it never should have been it
shouldn't have been they were trying to
get a wider audience i get it but you
know what i mean
well initially this was supposed to have
a theatrical release and they wanted to
see it so like i said anytime you're
trying to make something like that a
pg-13 and not
an r although i will say that the the
woman i can't remember what her name is
right now but the woman that played um
that played his bastard son's mom
i've seen her in other things but i
can't remember what her name is she was
like pretty funny and she got away with
like a lot of lines that i was surprised
that she got away with like in a pg-13
um but i guess she didn't say things i
don't know it was just like the way she
said stuff was like really
vulgar even though it wasn't really
swearing which i thought was really
funny
yeah but um like i said there was a lot
of [ __ ] i liked about this i liked
um i liked the plot line of you know
eddie murphy
being such a you know a rebel that
wanted to like find his own woman when
he was
younger and then kind of falling into
the same trap as his dad and like oh i'm
being all traditional blah blah like i
like that that was a good thing to
explore
i feel like they should have done more
with that i feel like they should have
done more with the daughters
i didn't mind um the bastard sun
character
but i thought like the romance between
him
and um what was his uh hair person's
like marimba marimba
that was her character's name um i
thought it was a good idea like for the
romance there but it's like i felt like
it was underdeveloped and also i felt
like he wasn't
you know he was fine but he wasn't like
as interesting a character
yeah you know what i mean to kind of
hang a whole movie on
t t's in there she called it all right
the kiss of death for the thing was the
damn pg rating
should have never done that never should
have been a hard r
nc 17 been subversive and [ __ ] funny
had to push them down boundaries on this
[ __ ]
um but i understand that it's got it had
an audi
it it had his f it had a family theme
you know because he's dealing with his
family there's kids and [ __ ]
so i guess they felt they should make it
a pg movie and they're like fun for the
whole family but it was kind of but then
it was kind of weird but then they had
that yeah but then they had like some
kind of media movie stuff
yeah kind of you know real crass yeah
kind of [ __ ] like they would have so it
was like
that the character he was playing was
like ludicrous and yeah he just
ramped the ludicrous up he was having a
[ __ ] ball
yeah actually ludicrous but
general button aiken well that's what i
was thinking yeah
we did a show on general butt naked i
could contact general butt nick i'd like
to have him
yeah we'll keep having a spare in the
spare room and [ __ ] show up
i would love to do a show with general
butt naked
[Laughter]
because you know we have a lot in common
you know with military backgrounds and
[ __ ] [ __ ] and i understand where he's
coming from but i wanted to tell stories
about you know [ __ ] cutting people's
heads off and
going on [ __ ] going on assault
[ __ ]
totally nude with the [ __ ] assault
rifle leading an army full of
[ __ ] men dressed like winning you
know
that was a crazy answer yeah don't bring
him into this house and i said yeah
that's super [ __ ] hilarious
i don't know i think that should be
hilarious man our show is hilarious
though
he's crazy i i honestly i don't know
yeah he's crazy but you know
it would be funny though i mean i think
he'd be [ __ ] real amusing
maybe i'm sure he'd be a blast take him
to the club
that's it yeah now we're getting in big
trouble take that [ __ ] to the club
it's an important military dictator
military
dignitary from military history yeah
yeah everybody be like general by the
we're not picture only person that's
done show about him so you know yeah
time suck did one too actually i haven't
watched it yet but i thought
he was copying us no it came out before
ourselves
but um yeah so but like i said wesley
snipes [ __ ] great in this
um i [ __ ] loved loved
the costume designs yeah holy [ __ ] now
the woman that did the costumes for the
same woman that did black panther so she
did all the like the wakanda stuff
and um i mean the costumes in this are
amazing amazing like like the
woman the woman who um who the bastard
son is supposed to marry
like general izzy's daughter what was
her name vapoto
when she comes in in that [ __ ] outfit
with the gold and like the hedge
oh my god yeah that was [ __ ] amazing
looking
yeah they're cool but all the costumes
in this are [ __ ] amazing
yeah and the musical numbers were
amazing yeah i loved all the songs songs
are good yeah i love that uh they had
sexual chocolate come back
which they'd done more of a soul glow
they had like a little call out to it
like i think the theme song was playing
on a tv or something like that but they
didn't have the guy back
maybe he wouldn't come back i don't know
they got like pretty much the whole
entire cast
other than um akeem's the woman that
played akim's mom
in the original movie i think she died
in the 90s so obviously she couldn't
come back
talk about her though yeah they do talk
about her but like she couldn't come
back but they pretty much got almost the
entire cast back for it
which i thought was was pretty cool and
it's time for a good it's time for a
good
wesley snipes movie i mean wesley snipes
he was he kind of stole dolomite too i
gotta say
not as much as he stole this one but i
would i
would have liked to like another 15 20
minutes of [ __ ] general izzy
yeah is that just a general izzy yeah i
love that
i was reading the um was it the av club
i can't remember i was reading some like
review of this
and they said something to the effect of
i'm paraphrasing but wesley snipes
comes in and steals the movie with no
getaway car
like in broad daylight with no getaway
car yeah and uh yeah i'm like yeah he
totally does because like i said he just
[ __ ]
leans into this [ __ ] it's amazing it's
amazing he works well with
on an eddie murphy production yeah
and like i said he was he was great in
dolomite yeah like
eddie eddie and his team really need to
work with him you know i mean he needs
to be like a regular
yeah but yeah he's he's good man i just
uh oh i can't i want it makes me want to
say i want to see blade again blade
three was bad but it wasn't his fault it
was that that was the [ __ ] director
all right and what he tried to do blade
three was about getting rid of blade and
for bringing in new characters [ __ ]
that's
it was [ __ ] and snipes knew that there
was no [ __ ]
blade three you can throw that one out
it was blade one and two
don't even if they came out with a new
blade movie with him as blade that'd be
[ __ ] great but the problem is is that
he's kind he's aged
yeah but you know he still looks good
though still looks i mean he looked good
in this movie he'd have to [ __ ]
um really get back in really good shape
and he's
he's got to be at least 10 years older
than me and um
to be you could do some of it with cg
you know trim him down in the waist area
maybe put him on a cycle steroids
[ __ ]
well you knew he had to bring that up
something yeah back up [ __ ]
well you could tell he was you know he
was in good shape
wouldn't surprise me if he did a couple
light cycles there for the blade series
most of these actors do
well plus now that we have cg and we
have all this stuff where you can make
really kick-ass suits where
you can just build a six-pack into the
suit yeah you don't even need that [ __ ]
right
[Laughter]
it's like we can just fix it in
post-production